if we act the wrong way we jumped too
soon then you could see a resurgence of
this disease that's something we should
all be really mindful of them so we get
one chance to get it right in this case
I'll call myself a conservative I think
we have to be smart about doing it
stages making sure we can confirm that
we're containing the disease more and
more getting it back to where it was you
know a month or two ago before you
really start to open up a lot and look I
want to see people back to work as much
as anyone I'm a field agent Lee but
we've got to secure the health and
safety first of all New Yorkers and
obviously all Americans so and then you
gotta wonder what states open up first
in with New York be at the bottom of
that list let's say I'll kill you in
Conway counselor to the president the
big focus this week in the Rose Garden
is getting the economy going again to
how we how reality based is May first
Kellyanne for some places it certainly
can be a reality if there is testing
available if your infection rates are
low your death rates are low your
hospital capacity is there including
ventilators and medical personnel beds
beds in the ICU all of that is taken to
account because the president's made
clear from the beginning that he's not
looking at a date he's looking at data
and he will listen to the health and
medical experts as well so these are
parallel tracks and they soon will join
now the mayor of New York City I agree
completely that he would be incredibly
cautious to look at am a first date or
anytime soon because New York City has
been a New York State had been among the
hardest hit about half of the deaths in
the entire country
sadly occurred in that have occurred in
that state but we have 24 percent of our
nation's counties that have had no
infections
we've got about 29 states that would
meet some of the criteria that I've put
out first but I think this is the
fundamental point here is that the best
person to revive the Donald Trump
economy is Donald Trump and with him in
the lead working with the governor's
working on that health and economic
guidance and now working with so many
leaders in the private sector who will
come forth and share their best
practices
talk about what they may want to do in
their places of work and I would say to
everyone take a look at what was put out
a week ago the CDC and the White House
put out updated guidance for critical
infrastructure workers that covered
about 16 different types of work
everything from our food supply to
energy waste management sanitation and a
number of different areas that are
considered to be critical infrastructure
that guidance also gives us a good look
ahead because we're talking about
whether you've been asymptomatic and
exposed never exposed temperature check
should happen here's how the facilities
in the places of work should continue to
sanitize their workplaces everybody
should continue the physical distancing
wearing a mask or a face cloth according
to the CDC's guidance of two weeks ago
now so there are protocols in place that
will continue this new normal that we've
all become accustomed to and that
Americans have been practicing routinely
so well - they're graded credit will
continue in our places of work so this
won't happen in New York I would doubt
it by a certain date any time soon but
it will happen in other places opening
up our places of worship our places of
work some of our schools and places
where children are also cared for seems
to be one of the major keys to unlocking
this economy this will be the great
American comeback we have 17 million
Americans who have filed for
unemployment one-third of renters did
not pay their rent last month this is
tragic for this country and it's through
no fault of those individuals we want
individuals and industries to come
roaring back in this Trump economy yeah
Kellyanne you mentioned the guidelines
and getting back to work a lot how will
we do this who will help with us will it
be guidelines that doctor foul she and
dr. Burks come up with or will it be
someone else both of the above they're
working hard on that so is the whole
team in the Situation Room most days
you've got the vice president dr.
Burke's doctor Falchi right like that I
sit right behind them in the second row
as to a number of White House staffers
we hear them every day they're working
it collaboratively on the health
outcomes talking about that the new
health outcomes for example state by
state county by county region by region
but now they're also talking into
about what it would take to open up
pieces of the economy so dr. Burks
obviously the coronavirus coordinator
here at the White House for the task
force and the head of the CDC dr.
Redfield along with FEMA CDC and FEMA
will have major big pens if you will in
terms of the guidance and what has to
happen and and that will be issued soon
but it is exactly that it's guidance and
then as the president made clear in the
Rose Garden last night the governor's
will come forward with their own plan
some of them are banding together for
regional discussions based on again
their needs and their interconnected I
guess market systems but again it took a
businessman to become president to juice
this economy in a fairly historic way
from modern times completing these trade
deals the unemployment rates were low
the taxes were lower all of that the
energy dominance the deregulation all
this created a booming economy for so
many Americans and this president helped
create that economy this president will
be in the lead to research that economy
right Gillian last night the president
did announce he was going to suspend
payments to the w-h-o as he tries to
figure out what exactly was going on
there
China clearly was deceptive at the early
stages of pandemic and the w-h-o
repeated a lot of that to the world as
if it was exactly accurate now there's a
story I'm looking at foxnews.com the
State Department has leaked cables that
were new theories on the origin of the
corona virus apparently two years ago
the State Department was concerned about
what was going on in a particular lab in
Wuhan what can you tell us about that
sure well that's all out in the public
domain everything that you just said
first let me take it the whu-oh funding
this is a president who recognizes that
our country ladies and gentlemen you the
taxpayers have paid eight hundred and
thirty-some million dollars over the
last two years to the w-h-o trying to
paint 10% of that China France Italy and
India combined paid about 1/10 of what
the United States of America is paid
into the World Health Organization
it's meant to coordinate responses and
keep an eye on things particularly in
the in the case of infectious diseases
for the entire world so we pay into that
and is it so much to ask the minor
dividend the minor return on our
investment would be for the whu-oh to be
honest about the origins of the virus in
wuhan about the fact that it was human
to human transmission they lied about
that or weren't transparent about that
so this is about transparency and
accountability because we've been so
hard hit in this country we were
listening to the health professionals
around the world
i sat in some of those early meetings
and we were getting Americans we were
repatriating them from Wuhan from other
parts in China the president took
decisive and immediate action the end of
January to shut down flights from China
that was criticized by the whu-oh it was
criticized by other people as in a
phobic and racist and travel bans don't
work well this one sure did so we have
every right to know and every right to
know because of what's happened here in
this global pandemic but there's another
reason some of the scientists and
doctors say that there could be other
strains later on this couldn't come back
in the fall in a limited way
this is Kovan 19 not covered one folks
and so you would think the people
charged with the World Health
Organization facts and figures would be
on top of that that this is just a pause
right now so there's an investigation
examination to what happened but people
should know the facts we paid over 830
million or the last two years China paid
10% of that right and we all should know
the facts that China fundamentally lied
and we still don't have the truth and
the w-h-o didn't stop it but China is
the problem I mean while the president's
trying to get this economy rebooted
again and he's calling on some experts
from all different aspects of our
economy
to pitch in one of which we hear is Mark
Cuban who's been a constant guest on on
our show and our network just saying he
wants to help out he's got over a
hundred businesses as well as he's got
that sports thing going with the NBA
well could you tell us about this well
there are many people involved and there
are people who will be involved who
aren't on the list who will participate
in calls and give advice as well the
list is illustrative I doubt it's
exhaust
because there are so many talented men
and women across this country who want
to bring to bear their successes their
best practices and their places of work
and figure out how they too can be part
of the great American comeback the
president of couple weeks ago had a
fabulous call with the heads of all the
sports leagues we know emotionally and
economically restarting some of our our
sports live sports action would go a
long way to showing America that it's
coming back but we've got small
businesses we've got captains of
industry really runs the gamut of the
private sector to actually combine with
all these public sector efforts the
Congress is passing trillions of dollars
in relief the president is working 24/7
the public sector FEMA naww been
tremendous and let me go back to one
thing you said about China I think this
is important but dr. Redfield dr.
Redfield said last week I'm sorry that
we had on February 8th we had 14 cases
in this country 14 we had had two
human-to-human transmissions and they
were spouses one in California one in
Illinois this just catapulted and you
know the w-h-o did not call this a
global pandemic until March I'd refer to
as a pandemic on your show as a lay
person before they had referred to it so
the foot-dragging is also a concern the
president wants to tap into private
industry public sector and get this
economy warming for many Americans right
thanks Kellyanne appreciate thank you
take care